تحولت مدينه بخموت في شرق اوكرانيا الى
مستنقع مع سقوط مئات القتل والجرح يوميا
في وقت لم تتمكن القوه الروسيه ولا
الاوكرانيه من تحقيق تقدم كبير بعد شهور
من الاقتتال هي مغامره يوميه للمتطوعين
الذين يبذلون قصار جهدهم للمساعده
الاكثر شيوعا هي اصابات انفجار الالغام من
القصف المدفعي وقذائف الهاون
اما بالنسبه الى الاصابات في المعارك
المباشره فهي اقل
90% من الجروح ناجمه عن متفجرات الالغام
ركزت معظم المعارك الاخيره على بلده
بخموطه المدمره بشكل شبه كامل والاتهاجرها
معظم سكانها البالغ عددهم 70,000 نسمه حيث
تواصلت معارك عنيفه مع سعيد موسكو الى
السيطره على المدينه والتحقيق انتصار بعد
سلسله من الانتكاسات
جندي واحد على الاقل سينضم لاحقا الى الصف
وجهدي لن يكون عبثا
بايظ
والاطباء الاخرانيون المحاصرون في هذه
الحرب
اصعب شيئا بالنسبه الي وبالنسبه لاي طبيب
هو موت جندي مصاب انه امر صعب دائما حتى
في وقت السلم وعند موت المرضى لكن الان
اكثر لان هذا الجندي كان بصحه جيده ثم ما
تل التوب
والجنود انتشارهم في الجبهه الجنوبيه
ويقولون ان القتال في محمود اكثر وحشيه
ولم يسبق لهم وان شاهدوا مثله